welcome to this video uhand Ibaka you
won the becau I've played him once and
lost that's not good from the UK and old
Indian or maybe kings and Nene still can
play g6 cfp can and he does ok that's a
sideline of the Kings Indian wear black
cam is kind of a risky and this is kind
of risky for Black this the sin idea is
somewhat our liability
young Knight takes Knight takes at the
end g4s hanging and this is a line that
I only recently looked at with a student
of mine so am I have some some memories
about it so what about what about this
just a three maybe a cover cover the
whole thing take it easy and just say
that this is Sir this is misplaced on a
six maybe there are more powerful ways
to play but that's definitely not bad
yeah I'm curious what is flex move okay
he's basically inviting me to step in to
e6 okay going to do it I guess well
let's let's have a moment of thought
here I can account I'm going to go there
so it's debatable maybe there's more
than one good way to play here but this
is definitely not bad okay so let's see
the problem is that his light squares
are so weak let's see okay let's just
want to play it play it quickly and not
get into huge time pressure trying to
refute this set up immediately and just
play some quick aggressive moves and
hope that they are right I'm tending a 7
now and let's just play it quickly
Bishop c5 is the next next idea yeah i
was thinking 95 should be quite good
here but maybe I'm wrong yeah I am wrong
I can just take it six really no that's
not good ship shakes
hmm yeah this is this is what happens to
me if I am playing quickly okay check
yeah the problem is this a 5 a-5 stuff
that really makes sure that he's getting
rid of this is weaknesses plus he's got
Bishop f8 yeah okay well c 6 is just bad
really really not doing doing in many
favors this move okay so let's see how
do I get do I need to get this back or
not 95 I can capture ok trying to double
on the D farm we don't know why what's
is six moths I mean this is not doing
anything
yeah this is the secret of done earlier
okay again is giving me giving me
squares okay I take this file as well
ok
rook d6 is also on the menu I can play
may I can still play it kinky 7i just
takes his six and he's still stuck stuck
to this hour interesting interesting now
I wonder can add can i play nightie for
maybe I'm trying this should be should
be interesting I had an idea it's not
like I'm always playing without any
ideas
I can take you cannot take now because
of 97 it's not so clear what else he
should play yeah and you're loading this
it just promotes black resigns it wasn't
really good I tried to play quickly
aggressively whatnot but it's really not
not any good the c5 maybe not a good
idea this is this is simple and good
actually intending a 7 now something
like that is very nice i mean this is
simply not a good piece and the ponies
read Ainger asst yeah this is i don't
know if this was a good idea ah this
this is interesting actually and then
not be eight this this is this is
interesting and this is some
compensation those pawns they completely
kill the bishop and either this is
interesting I can also go now here to
support my pawn yeah this was better
than than this yeah I was tempted by by
this poppy 8 and just leading to an Khe
position yeah Jim yeah I think I'm still
okay here computer also gives it as
equal but this there are some things
that will be it like this move here
giving up the v6 square
here I'm just better yeah 94 is
supported by the computer yeah it is it
should be really good because he night
c5 was most possible already but here it
is very difficult for him this is
hanging and I'm threatening all this why
does winning anyway it seems computers
on + 2.5 okay so I'm pretty nice win at
the end thanks for watching